welcome to the seminar on religion and
democratic pluralism the Indonesian
model and it is my great pleasure to
welcome our friends from Indonesia to
Yale to macmillan center and the
director of the religious freedom and
society project in Africa based at the
Macmillan Center I'd like to add my word
welcome to those of the ncpo who
welcomed us only a few minutes ago at
the Macmillan Center the director of the
Macmillan Center see I'd like to take
the opportunity to introduce our friends
and then the format is they will speak
on the issue of religion democratic
schools the Indonesian model and I have
some from primers which I picked up from
from their own writings and their own
reflections on the subject and I'll try
and present that as a way of priming the
pump and getting the discussion going
first of all I should express our
gratitude to the Amina Institute which
is headed as president by ambassador
Jacob Tobin in many ways really the
father of the Indonesian Constitution
and he was a member of the National
Committee for the first democratic
elections in Indonesia and laid the
foundation for democracy by rewriting
the Constitution in the Parliament of
1999 2002 and it transformed the world's
largest muslim-majority country with 260
million people into the world's third
largest democracy and afterwards he
served as ambassador to South Korea
where he orchestrated masterminded
summit between Indonesia and North
Korea's head of state and president of
the Supreme People's Assembly South
Korea's president as well Prime Minister
Lee a charm for his service he was
awarded the gang war medal of the
Republic of Korea's highest diplomatic
award
he received an MPA from the John F
Kennedy School of Government at the
other place on the river Charles I will
also take time to introduce dr.
al-wahhab
who is Indonesia the president of
Indonesia special invited Middle East
and the Organization of Islamic
countries or I see he was formerly the
coordinating minister for people's
welfare and the foreign minister of
Indonesia leading scholar on interfaith
relations between Muslims and Christians
in particular he is the author of the
best-selling book the inclusive Islam
toward an open attitude in religion he
also serves on the board of trustees of
the Hartford seminary not far from us
here in Hartford and advisor to the
Council of Fetzer Institute that
promotes love forgiveness and compassion
he was a visiting scholar at Harvard's
Center for the Study of all religions
where I myself spent many years on the
faculty there he the recipient of two
doctoral degrees in iron charms universe
in Cairo and Temple University
in Philadelphia dr. Herman's Abdullah
who was my wonderful host at the
University State University of Jakarta
in January the professor of Islamic
philosophy and the first rector of the
state Islamic University of Jakarta
he determined of the Indonesian Academy
of Sciences cultural Commission his work
on religion and science and integration
and interconnection have greatly
influenced Islamic higher education in
Indonesia a prominent column Quranic
hermeneutics of fear he developed a new
hermeneutical approach to the quran and
advocates a new path in islamic
epistemology that is open to dialogue
and integration with many different
sources of knowledge his PhD from the in
philosophy Islamic philosophy from the
Middle East Technical University in
Turkey with postdoctoral study at McGill
in Canada dr. as ahmadi Ezra is one of
South Asia's Southeast Asia's most
distinguished Muslim intellectuals his
professor of history and the vice
president and also vice president and
visiting professor New York University
at Oxford University of Melbourne and
many others he is the author of many
many books and articles in English and
Arabic and for his outstanding services
he was awarded the commander of the most
excellent Order of the British Empire
CBE by the Queen by queen elizabeth ii
and the Fukuoka Prize in Japan
he completed three master's degrees and
doctorate degree at Columbia University
and finally last but not least like
Mattia for who is co-founder of the
lamella Institute an executive director
of the Institute he spearheaded
development of leadership and
citizenship program to Train leaders in
churches and other institutions in
Indonesia
he was formerly director and money of a
manufacturing company and a management
consultant in Indonesia and Singapore he
is a founding trustee of John stores
Langham ministry in Indonesia
he received his BS and MS from the
University of Wisconsin in Madison
Wisconsin and studied at the Institute
of Contemporary Christianity in London I
make these introductions as a way of
getting myself out of the way
and have them with ambassador tubing
leading our discussion and my idea is
that we will open the discussion to the
audience after they've had a chance to
speak on the subject of the seminar and
I've picked up some of the themes that
will come up I think in our conversation
here the first is that of the world's
largest Muslim country Indonesia is
committed to the course of moderate
Islam population is 255 260 million of
which Muslims are ages 7.2% more than
seventeen thousand eight hundred islands
with 525 languages and dialects two very
very rich country from that point of
view the second is that mother's Islam
is being promoted in Indonesia on the
banner of middle path Islam the
Indonesians call it was Atia a term
based on the verse in the Quran kadala
kanakam Oh Martin Watson
it says in the Quran I have therefore
created you made you a community of the
middle button wasn't there the rumor
there is community and in many ways
Indonesia the political system is based
on this concept of community pancasila
itself is not the internal Dean or the
five pillars of faith but suddenly the
five pillars of community solidarity and
integration so mother's Islam is viewed
as a pillar of Indonesian system of
government which is a pluralist
democracy that fosters religious
tolerance fourth religious pluralism
therefore is regarded as very important
for democracy as a whole in Indonesia
five Indonesia is committed to opposing
radical Islam including Wahhabi radical
ideas of Islam six days groups in civil
society are recognized as indispensable
to the climate of political moderation
and religious tolerance the climate that
inspired the Indonesian Constitution
based on Pancasila the five principles
that make up the basis of the
constitutions in Indonesia the point of
Silla
I should have summarized the principles
of tanta sila belief in the absoluteness
of god
justice and civilized humanity the kind
of ethical humanism really founded the
unity of indonesia democracy for
democracy guided by what they call inner
wisdom participative democracy open
democracy and finally social justice
all the peoples of Indonesia definitely
pancasila where I have to face friends
we're delighted to welcome you here is
our honor and a privilege ambassador
told you to welcome you and your
association colleagues to Yale it
doesn't amplify honestly Chris okay yes
you're first of all thank you very much
for you know arranging this seminar and
thank you for your moderating this
session good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen so I think professor
Lamine has elaborated many aspects of
Indonesian democracy so I just want to
emphasize some aspect of that we began
our reform process with a democratic
election conducted in 1999 and
participated in by 48 political parties
this is a democratic election and you
know it's observed by international
observers including from Carter Center
from here from European Union and from
other places in the world and that 48
political parties it ranged from center
a little bit left to the right but then
the result of the election shows that
people tends to vote for this middles
raised of political orientation so
this process of amending the
Constitution is conducted in a very open
ways so we invited also scholars or
political or activists from like from
the United States from South Africa from
Germany Great Britain's from South Korea
Thailand and every other part of the
world
besides people's from Indonesia itself
and it was conducted in the deliberation
ways and by consensus in a unplanned
four stages of process from 1999 to 2002
so from hundreds of decision taken
during the process or agreement that
achieved during the process all of them
is achieved through consensus except one
it's about the existence of the
representatives of the military of the
functional group appointed members in
people's assembly in this voting the
members of the military and police voted
against the existence of appointed
members and yeah because of this process
is conducted in a deliberative phase and
emphasizing consensus it's a when very
slow and sometimes rambling but that
situation where everybody thinks or
feels sense of ownership of the process
because no votes or no decision is taken
by majority takes all approach so even
the smallest faction can contribute as
much as possible as long as it is
acceptable by the others and that during
the process there there were no attempt
to make Indonesia and Islamic state
there is no attempts to make Islam as
the state religion while in our history
actually we had this tent
aided by you know peaceful domestic
waste using real times or by the bloody
rebellions in some parts of the country
which cost thousands of lives but then
we have this all these things change and
we can achieve this achievement
peacefully and I could say that the very
strategic factors that enable us to have
such a situation is one is our inclusive
nationalism you know Indonesia never
nation before it is a new nation which
declared in the 1928 in the what we call
as super kumuda yes pledge and the state
itself we never had Indonesia as a state
before 1945 before this archipelago
consisted of six hundreds of kingdoms
Sultanate in such Scylla
organization and yeah by this yeah
thanks to our founding fathers and
founding mothers yeah this very
heterogeneous peoples declared
themselves accepted themselves as one
nation and the second strategic factors
important practice is the existence of
this Vaisakhi I is LOM which comprised
of almost 90 percent of the population
which most of them belongs to that
latter ulama and muhammediye he which
very inclusive as well and very used to
harmonious living together with others
that enable us to have this situation so
I can say that this sister kind of
proves that actually Islam is compatible
with democracy and some distinct
characteristic of our new modified
Constitution is we have all these
[Music]
principles of constitutionalism
incorporated in the our Constitution for
instance of the peoples of relative by
Constitution we have to have a regular
theoretical five years circulation of
powers so it is one of the aspect of our
people's sovereignty addresses the
adherence of human rights the human
rights
including freedom of religions and also
freedom of expression is one of the
basic rights which is we can classify it
as categorized as non alienable
non-delegable rights and also the
principles of rule of law and i can say
that this constitution is a kind of
prescriptive constitution rather than
just nominal pseudo democratic
constitution the sometimes there are
Constitution which declared themselves
democracy like people Democratic
Republic often but actually they are not
democracy we have beside this principles
we have institutions we have procedures
stipulated in our Constitution how to
implement this critical for instance
Human Rights which is incorporated held
by the Constitution and a consistent
stated that the government and the state
is responsible and must uphold this
human rights principles I think this is
some of the achievement that we have and
we do it in a peaceful way so we are
prevented from like a vulcanization
process that happened in some
discoveries and you know that after 15
years almost in this democracy now we
are members of the g20 countries it's
already the ninth the ninth and some
report says that if every
Ringo's well no serious digital
disturbances within 20 to 25 years
Indonesia will be among the four or five
largest economy in the world and also
the Gini coefficient also reducing
however lately because of some
negligence of in our side and
consolidating our democracy on one side
on the other side of this the global
flows of like decadence way of life the
the materialism disseminated deeply and
very fast through this digital
information system while on the other
hand we also have this poverty and also
this injustice discrepancy between the
poor and perhaps this created some kind
of situation where other ideas in this
case the radicals have a very you know
fertile ground to provoke and many of
the years and many of the idealist is
prone to this provocation and we can see
that the penetration of the radicals in
Indonesia
is growing to an extend to an alarming
act and as we can see among others from
what is going on or what's happening in
regard with the election of the governor
of Jakarta we plan this trip a joint
partnership trip of interfaith long
before the the election of in Jakarta so
not that the motivation has landed
Jakarta is what happening Jakarta is I
think a combination of many
things not just religious or political
economic rivalry and anything but
however it's a yeah alerted us that this
is alarming those many schools many
centers in Excel in elite areas schools
mosque public schools private schools
have been penetrated quite deeply by
this radical so we are we have to do
some things to maintain this democracy
to maintain this harmonious cooperation
in our society to achieve a better and
better
development in the features I think
that's what I would like to offer in
Jesus thank you thank you very much I
think we should go on the list as I have
it yeah which is to ask next doctor she
opted to intervene at this point thank
you so much I will be a brief so to give
you more time see actually people the
panelists of what you have in your mind
to know about Indonesia as was mentioned
that we in tradition we cherish the
success of democracy and pluralism and
it has been praised commanded by many as
the model for Muslim populated country
most of Indonesia's almost 90% Muslim
but at the same time maintain that
respect to other religion
communities of faith and present itself
as a model of pluralism as we know that
Indonesia as mentioned is a democratic
country Islam occupies significant
position in its policies and has been
able to influence political discourse
and practices but what kind of Islam we
can differentiate the Islamic practices
and Islam make understanding into a
rigid exclusive and inclusive Islam and
open-minded Islam we are proud to have
the exclusive and open-minded Islam and
therefore our relation as Muslim
majority with other communities of faith
our corbeil friendly and we have never
had any major disputes hostility I said
major because there was a minor incident
with regard to communal problem
religiously but in general we are
respecting and living in harmony with
other communities of faith as we know
Indonesia recognized six religions and
we can list
harmoniously as Indonesia
even though Indonesia has 90 almost 90%
Muslim but Muslim never imposed on
having an Islamic space or religion of
Islam as the religion of the state
however after presenting this good news
let me try to alert all of us about the
seemingly bad news towards not only
Indonesia but towards the most Muslim
countries and also Western countries
with regard to be rising and increasing
presence of radicalism pluralism
requires open-minded attitude and we in
Indonesia accept this democracy and
compatibility with modernity and Islam I
think mostly attributed to the societal
values and people's character and and
attitude we know Indonesian are non
contracted non confrontative people they
are a consensus seeking people they
respect others to extend but sometimes
you are not aware if your interlocutor
is angry or upset yes too
get that Corby relation between you and
this is something that we cherish and
Indonesia and you can see the character
of most Indonesian are friendly to the
extent that people do not know them
because they never create any noisy
appearance and not
yeah but any anything that could create
tension among themselves and therefore
the increasing presence of radicalism in
the world and also we feel it Indonesia
is an alarming phenomena and we really
have to do something as a collective
responsibility among ourselves as
Indonesian at the same time with the
global community and I think one of the
aim of our visit to Europe and United
State is to present the good news and
also the unpleasant news with regard to
the increasing penetration of the rigid
understanding of Islam the close-minded
understanding of Islam and the exclusive
way of interpreting Islam as a whole I
think we need a systematic counter to
how this first penetration one of which
is we have to try effectively to use
media to enlighten our people to counter
the argument of those exclusive
understanding of the teaching of Islam
through media through social media
through radio because most of our
Indonesian news are not quite
knowledgeable about what is Islam is all
about when we talk about democracy we
talked about the compatibility of
democracy and Islam lack of knowledge is
something that lead them into an astray
or deviated way of understanding this
one and therefore enlightenment is very
important to try to lead them into the
right path and as mentioned that
Indonesian Muslims are having this
middle way Islam meaning that
non-extremist understanding of Islam
very soft Islam and this is attributed
to the two largest Islamic organization
in the country namely Naruto Rama was
founded in 1926 and before that Medea
founded 1912 those two organizations are
a middle path character in educating
Muslim in Indonesia this is a homegrown
organization only lately with the
important
the Islamic organization as network in
the Middle East mostly now started to
penetrate Indonesian Muslims and to
influence them to be more radical and to
see that there is another Islam which
suit their psychological need and as
mentioned radicalism not only because of
ideological factor but there are many
factors at play the gap between the
haves and the have-nots the rampant
corruption and there is also something
called yeah the gap between the poor and
the rich created a lot of frustration
and therefore when radicalism when the
new ideology introduced to Indonesia
they are attracted to this ideology and
therefore it is important and it is
imperative that we have to empower the
two largest organization Mohammed en a
new and at the same time we have to try
to reform our education our curriculum
and at the same way we need to empower
the newly emerging
youth organization which could be left
into the middle path understanding of
Islam thank you
thank you very much and we'll come back
to sew these issues including the
challenge of radical Islam which as you
suggest is not homegrown but it's
actually and external influence we have
next Doctor as you Mahdi as from the TV
State Islamic University in Jakarta
where I had a wonderful time here's my
host it was a very good afternoon ladies
and gentlemen there has been a lot of
has been said about the compatibility it
will be so many more pristine Indonesia
and of course I think I believe that
Indonesia is indeed a so crest of
compatibility between Islam and
democracy when they when Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton they have her
visit to Indonesia she told me that if
somebody asked her about work and where
he or she couldn't find from the
compatibility between the Islam and
democracy modernity hi women position
and Hillary Clinton said I would suggest
him or her to visit Indonesia so this is
the impression of Hillary Clinton about
the compatibility of Islam and democracy
actually the indonesian muslim experian
big democracy is not true muslims
accepted democracy since the very
formation refereed in the first day of
Declaration of Independence on August 17
1945 and in early November 1945 Vice
President Mohammed Atta declared I
appeal to the people to form political
parties because Indonesian leader agreed
to have democracy competitive democracy
so so as a result we had our first
competitive liberal democracy in the
election 1955 this is the very first mo
democratic elections but unfortunately
in nineteen in 1959 Sukarno introduced
what he call as guided as a guided
democracy because he he felt that
liberal democracy had been very divisive
among people there's a lot there was a
lot of quarrel among politician among
people so he introduced guided democracy
which is basically is only a guise of so
Sukarno authoritarianism civilian of
course so we had civilian authorities
authoritarianism between 1955 to 1965
when su carto when fair communist coup
d'etat force
Sukarno to basically to transfer power
to general fato and later Suharto of
course also introduced Pancasila
democracy
with the regular election we had a
regular election with three parties
involved but of course democracy is more
than this modern regular election we
need of course vibrant civil society we
need freedom of association win it we
press so that we gain after the monetary
economic and political crisis since the
late 1997 1998 in May 1998 Suharto
decided to resign from power and then
vice president Habibi
became a new president and happy be
introduced soon enough to introduce you
know liberal democracy competitive
democracy multiparty democracy I think
we owe a lot of debt to Habibi received
aa BB femto is interregnum is very very
very shot less than two years and our
first president democratic
democratically elected president was
Abdul Rahman white only called as a
booster and the Speaker of people
consultative assembly was Amin rice
these two leaders when they were you
know elected in their position were in
fact the national leader of two largest
Muslim organization that has been
mentioned earlier abdomen whiteness was
the national leader of narottama the
revival of unum that was established
long time ago in 1926 in opposition to
the rise of Wahhabism inside
the Arabia in Mecca and Medina in the
Hejaz and the second largest
organization muhammediye was was only
even earlier in 1912 so I believe these
two organ and of course there are many
other smaller organization similar
organization of course across the
country they are guardian of you know
Indonesia Islam I arise I love to argue
that in origin Islam is not only wisata
Islam but is a flower Islam colorful
Islam which which with local tradition
progress or omission I think you observe
it in Duke jacket area you can call it
also a relaxing if relaxed Islam that's
the test that doesn't mean that we are
less Islamic you know if you come to
Jakarta visit Indonesia during Ramadan
and then you you feel it that Ramadan is
most observable in Indonesia if you
compare it with some some somewhere else
you can you can even also read some
research by scholars let's say by
Professor Nikki Cady of UCLA in 1986
comparing male Muslims in Jakarta Cairo
in Tehran in the royalty - - - a prayer
and she found that indonesian muslim
male Muslims Muslim el are the most
royal I think more than 90% we are going
to to do Juma prayer while in Cairo
Egypt Egypt only 70 percent and tension
is only around 30 31 percent because why
because in telling you you have only one
most to resume a prayer
but Indonesia you can you can find most
everywhere well why you can find most
everywhere Indonesia because two pi is
not holiday in Indonesia it is working
day so they have to pray in their office
or in probably in a mall McNall it many
places well in the Middle East Friday is
holiday so you can find most mostly only
in the neighborhood neighborhood a dead
end in in offices or something like that
so so this is very distinct you can I
can also refer you to a comparative
study by professor Ria's hazard on the
Muslim headlines about you know the
degree of let's say believing in God in
the Prophet Mohammed loyalty to let's
say freak for instance Islamic
jurisprudence Muslim faith lines and let
the last I think I can also refer you to
research done by Professor Robert Hafner
of Boston University
comparing again Muslim practices so so I
saw us that's why I always appeal to
indonesian muslim not to be to have some
kind of inferior inferiority complex we
service our Muslim brothers and sisters
somewhere else
so if enter again event Oh Islam is
embedded in Indonesian is embedded in
local culture but again it doesn't mean
that indonesian muslim are less islamic
compared to muslim somewhere else
the problem is with indonesian muslim
they are low profile like professor
alicia upset we don't want to speak out
mostly touch that's why the role of
Indonesia in the Islamic world was very
minimal why because Indonesia doesn't
punch it wait in international diplomacy
Indonesia should play a greater role try
to mediate you know conflict somewhere
somewhere else even though now
Indonesian civil society are more active
in let's say in giving relief support to
Myanmar to Rohini and also even to
Palestinian Indonesian relief
organization has been successful to
contract a big Hospital in Gaza now they
are also going to build a new hospital
in the area of course this is not state
budget but philanthropic Islamic plan
tropic budget so now I think our
challenge to the future because we
already talked about the implication of
the radical I think this is one of
unintended of many unintended
consequences for democracy in the first
five years of of democracy liberal
democracies since night since they're
the first election 1999 almost every day
we hate demonstration so that's why in
video we call the more crazy
rather than democracy they're more crazy
rather than the more democracy of course
the number of demonstration now is is
less compared to in the period let's say
5 in the 5300 democracy so this is the
first one the second one I think also
breakdown of law and order police has
been criticized by civil society
organization because the day to not take
decisive and firm action any radical
group
baxlo into their own hands the most
notorious of course I know you know the
Islamic different from led by rejection
in the cotton but we are fortunate this
I think
jokowi president vegetable is firm
firmer against radical but not president
SBY SPI often condom you know violent
radical groups by accepting depth in
their office for instance so I think we
need to consolidate our democracy we
should accelerate the creation of good
governance as long as corruption is
rampant and then I see there are people
who love to take laws into their home or
hands in particularly in in local areas
because now people said that during
Swatow period we had we had corruption
only in central department but now with
the implementation of local autonomy
there has been some kind of
decentralization of corruption so many
mayor and source district tip and of
course registers governor's have been
have been inputted into prison because
of corruption cases the last point is
that while another intended consequences
of democracy is the rise of religious
political groups that have strong
orientation to the Middle East like his
boot party Indonesia party of liberation
in India
the HDI actually was introduced
initially during rattle but they they
were lying low because of course they
cannot campaign for creation of
Caliphate for implementation of Sharia
because you know you cannot say that you
will soon be you know be captured be
detained by the by the military but now
after the introduction of liberal
democracy actually SETI you know
campaign for Caliphate and also Sharia
openly openly and the government cannot
bend it they not make HTT a illegal like
light in other countries in the Middle
East
his behavior is displayed also in
Central Asia also even in Malaysia but
not in Indonesia so this is a problem
there is a lot of discussion now among
lawmakers in Malaysia how to to to
create allow that law or regulation that
would that will allow police or
government to bend this kind of Islamic
groups and also it is also related to
the law and law on anti-terror for
instance now it is is going to be
revised in the parliament because the
law is quite me if Indonesian returned
let's say from Isis like I think two
weeks ago there are some people who
returned who deported who are deported
by Syria by Turkish authorities to
Indonesia and the defragment Indonesian
government and police cannot attended
the most they can they can do is only to
interview them that's one
so this is also problems so the key I
think for Indonesian problem now is as I
suggested first is of course continued
consolidation of democracy we need to do
to bring credibility to the political
party suppose loss of credibility and
accountability of the power of political
parties and that we need also to
accelerate the creation of good
government good governance and also more
decisive law enforcement and to be much
thank you very much indeed and dr. Amin
Abdullah was also my host yogyakarta
where we arrived on a very hot afternoon
and had a wonderful visit in the
boarding school of the new Mahad Colin
Cooper garlic yeah quite amazing we
thought you couldn't answer the boarding
school in the United States I had for
many reasons over to you
okay thank you good afternoon everybody
it is not easy to speak in the last
minute the easiest ways is parappa
what has been clarified by my colleagues
the key issues actually is the word
religions here what do we mean by by
religions and especially if it is
connected with the pluralism and then in
the middle is the word democratic Muslim
acceptance of Pancasila actually is the
root of pluralism in
if in that time in 1945 Muslim doesn't
didn't accept pancasila so there will be
no Indonesia there will be no such kind
of Indonesian model as it is mentioned
our topic today so I would like to to to
underscore this that the Muslim
acceptance of the pancasila actually is
the root of Brutalism
in Indonesia as my colleagues expressed
that Buddhist pancasila so yeah this is
the the intellectual genuinity of our
founding fathers and mothers because you
know that in Turkey turkey experienced
with their secularism like friends
secularism and also America also have
this type of governance and Indonesia of
course select the the new terminology
which is suitable for the context of
Indonesia
so that is why president Sukarno in that
time in 1945 in this speech on Jocelin
it consists of five items as my
colleague explained it the process the
belief in the Supreme Court I will not
mention the others because my colleague
already but what has it been belief in
the Supreme Court so this is
actually the most important one when
Sukarno explained this issue because it
means that all indonesian people believe
in God it may be the further development
if the difference with the friends
understanding of what is God in this
faith but what does it mean it is in the
sense that a Christian belief in God in
harmony with the beating of Jesus Christ
and Muslim also believe in God in
accordance with Mohammed teaching and
also Buddhist Hindu also they believe in
God in accordance with their holy
scripture so in that way the Indonesian
state is a state where all believer can
worship God in according with his own
choice of religions so it's exactly like
what we have you here in United States
similar in the United States so
Indonesian people believe in God in a
refined meaning in refinement meaning
means that believing in God without egg
wisdom without egg wisdom in the name of
any religion be Christian Muslim or
those things okay so then the example is
my city for example Islam in sanik
prophet Solomon
a bizarre-o job Jakarta City suit
Agartha the 20% of its inhabitants are
Christians and 80% are Muslim but the
relationships between evidence of
religions in to Jakarta is very very
clearly very very democratic and
peaceful and peaceful and harmonious
life so this is the type Indonesian
model when you compare it with what
happens in Egypt for example of course
there is some cases local situations but
it is not national situations so subtly
speaking there are three elements with
mix indonesian muslim as model could end
good for our contemporary and difficult
situation today the first is that
plurality inclusiveness is the very very
picture of indonesia from religions from
ethnicity and from any any other kinds
of typical issues the second one the
social cohesiveness is the cultural and
social mode or capital indonesia so you
can find religious life solidarity
cordial smiling and so forth it is very
very indonesian type of Muslim and the
first one this is the most typical
actually the indonesian muslim can
combine between the islamic belief the
islamic teaching and the common good of
the nation state so this is the most
simple very very difficult
listen because the challenge from
radical today they are asking about this
issue the equation about this issue but
I I myself believe that as long as the
Indonesian people have greased these
three elements so the Indonesian model
can be a very good example actually but
if we cannot depend on this three
element so we cannot differentiate what
happens in the Middle East and also in
other parts of the Muslim thank you well
thank you very much so many issues there
pluralism which has come up quite a bit
social cohesion also trying to fill out
the basis of the Constitution I the two
lessons I came away with from individual
among other things the first is in terms
of the political project of Indonesia
its pluralism diversity inclusiveness
it's the point that the government the
state cannot transcend the Society of
its jurisdiction and so Pancasila if you
like gave birth to the Indonesian
Constitution we gave birth to the state
and the state has to let them reflect
this tremendous diversity and
inclusiveness and the commitment which
is grounded in civil society the second
is that Indonesia does not play a
statistical game and say doesn't a lot
political power according to numerical
strength or lack of strength and it cuts
both ways majority Muslim population is
not asking for privileges that are
proportionate to its to its strength to
it
Numerical sentence society that way but
the other way also it comes namely that
small communities in Indonesia Hindus
are about on the 2% of the population
the other groups in the society that are
minority groups are not excluded by
virtue of their size or that number and
it seems to me what makes that work is
that punch of Silom acts as a kind of
binding cohesive element of civil
society and government reflects in its
inner character operations anyway over
to you we've had a rich diet here and so
what you go to nibble this cornucopia of
ideas any question it has been so clear
nobody who was authorized to fly out
yeah ok so excuse the panels are very
rich and any discussion I I thinking a
lot about the media discourse of
Indonesia and there's a certain shift in
the winning which immediate rebel is a
trade and one of the challenges I think
to the idea of our intuitive Islam in
Indonesia is the increasingly close ties
with Seoul area for example there's a
lot being said in there about the little
bit of Saudi rulers to to Indonesia
in March and I'm wondering is if you
could comment on on the changing
relationship between Indonesia and the
countries of the Middle East and whether
this is a warranted focus or something
that that is definitely the sort of
impact of Indonesian society I think
Indonesia and Middle East and especially
Saudi Arabia has a long traditional
relation cordial relation just to give
you an example that the founders of two
largest organization we are studying in
Mecca but on the other hand Saudi
Arabia's and the spending and of the
Islamic teaching is a different school
of thought that has been introduced and
practiced and conveniently accepted by
the whole Indonesian and therefore it
created sort of tension sometimes
because when the cleric of the Saudis
with good intention wanted to explain
the priest in Islam or the pure Islam as
they see that could create problem with
regard to the majority of Muslim who has
been practicing Islam on other
understanding or other school of thought
thinking but I think Saudi Arabia and
Indonesia is trying to
do a sort of mutual understanding the
Saudis know exactly that Indonesian
Islam or Indonesian understanding of
Islam is different and we do nishan
[Music]
people government level and organization
we are trying to inform and to enlighten
them that we are not in a position to
switch to an understanding that is
incompatible with our culture our
culture is accepting in inclusive
culture we embrace all religious
communities as part of the whole family
while they there they don't have that
kind of pluralism so we are trying our
best to create that mucha understanding
can I prefer actually it is not new the
Saudi Arabian government and private
institution try to influence the course
of Islam Indonesian Islam would say
particularly with the rise of Saudi
Arabia as a petrodollar country since
the early 1980s and as how this were in
a bitter competition with Iran of course
Ayatollah Khomeini Islamic Revolution of
1979 was you know I mean the Iranian
government try to import to export this
Islamic Revolution including to
Indonesia in order to topple what they
call what the Iranian regime call as the
you know authoritarian regime of flat
origin at the time of course but I don't
think I don't I don't I don't I don't
think that after how many almost fair
almost four decades of the you know hard
work of Saudi Arabia and also even to X
to export their brain of Islam I don't
see any much progress
actually there are not many Indonesian
convert to hobbies herbs particularly
among the MU not at all allama members
in from the very term Wahhabi were
happier or Wahhabism is anathema it is a
pejorative because they practice and
practice of a besom run contrary to the
practice of of nineteen of you know not
a new members for instance just to take
to give you an example for instance and
you a new people have a very you know
fun of doing religious visitation the
cr-z are as to the tomb of the saint or
grr to the predecessors something like
that so i said that indonesian in
general cannot live without tombstone
well in saudi arabia you cannot find
tombstone
so for indonesian mohab ism is very very
dry and primitive dry and primitive
while in origin I love to particularly
the Japanese to have a deep religious
experience so that's why Sufism is very
very strong in Indonesia some of Sufism
have been transformed into Cavatina
or Kajal a Japanese mysticism some of
them so so I'm not you know if you let's
say if you go to Jakarta for instant
here it is very difficult to find any
single mosque that has been built by
Saudi money no only one most that partly
financed by the Saudi money that is re
re re from animals that belong to
University of Indonesia through certain
deal the problem some people call it
dirty deal deal you know get probed I
don't know how much probably fifty fifty
billion dollar rupiah but at the same
time didn't festival ninja granted an
honorary doctoral degree to the Saudi
King a director of University of
Malaysia you know with some I don't know
how many fly flew all the way to to
react to bring the certificate of dr.
hood or even or religiously so it is
very difficult I think this is also
related to the nature to the very nature
of Indonesian Islam which is very
independent he saw he said you know I
think nine mostly more than 99% of
Islamic institution including mosque
particularly most bill by Muslim
themselves they got the gun they get no
violence from you know subsidy from
Department except probably one or two
the so-called state most Sukarno
presidents Varma was very ashamed to
find that in Russia there is there is a
mosque even named Sukarno's mosque but
in Jakarta there is no statement so he
decided to build the most later named
mystic club indepen
but every other Muslim have been billed
by Muslim particularly I think in in
1980s with the rise of Muslim middle
class I remember when I first came to
Jakarta in 1975 there were only two you
know beautiful mosque big mosque India
Tata
the first one is for stickler the second
one is Azhar mosque in Kabul Ranmaru but
now you can find you know many many
beautiful mosques in Jakarta or any
other places so okay any other questions
we have about 10 minutes or so we have
to go when the Olympics I'm at the
controls in the government has a lot to
be so inclusive in research diversity
and culture that sounded is probably
Islam as I said earlier that numbers is
not translated protocol power what is it
about the structure in the iris that
really allows that to occur
I think part of filler is one one clue
into that but I the region friend
student but will be cut up into here yes
for instance in a consensus agreement
the requirement for a president is only
that he must be or she must be a in the
nation from the birds like in
in genetic Adria and it's a of course
has a long roots to our cultures and to
the yeah thanks again cuz our founding
fathers and own images that educate the
peoples that yeah in this relationship
with the state affairs you cannot
discriminate people because of their
lives you know the real the genuine
attitude of the Indonesian people from
all over the the island we have more
than 1000 ethnicities more than 700
languages is that we are trained to live
together to respect each others so it
gets a result of a long history that we
live together Joe you might say
something yourself tolerance of Muslims
for Muslims we think Indonesia and since
I miss we have their product if I was
practicing at a it's a very different
sort of this one from that practice in
East Java and the five were in far
radical in Indonesia I would look away
and say that's the future of
country zone so I wonder if you can
speak to the eternal heterogeneity of
Islam as including Indonesia itself and
what that effect might have on future
issues politics yeah you don't unto me
I think you need to change your
perspective because now if you want to
see the radical the origin of the
radicals you can find mostly Japanese
not a Chinese look what happened you
know with ambrosia and many terrorists
that had been detained by the police or
have been sentenced by the court
mostly clapping come from Java including
also in Passau you know in Amman
communal conflict they came from Java I
think now of course I agree with you
there should be strengthening of
tolerance among Muslim because
particularly in the case of the election
in Jakarta Muslims have been you know a
case of infidel being invaded by you
know the supporter of certain group by
Muslim you know conservative or radical
zero have been occlusive of being
infidel so not only you know the
Christian but also even Muslim have been
accused yes thank you
so in other cases I think it's a special
case the government tolerate this kind
of special law in a case to as a cause
for a peaceful agreement so to save
lives thousands of people had died and
to some extent we can thanks to the
tsunamis
which open the opportunity to you know
to have a deal actually if the
government that the military crashed the
gum the the hf movement during that
period where when they were so so weak
it's the time but then we the government
find that we must have a peaceful
solution and one indicate and the
purpose is to bring them step by step to
integrate to other part of the society
and this kind of sorry allowing in it's
not popular among the people protect
themselves and one of the indication is
that the image a we have no control
itical parties so I think to assure them
that quite seen as a powerful party and
all others national political political
parties also exist and active in that
province step by step in the in the
election now the national political
parties is the majority and the locals
is you know decreasing so yeah we should
be patient and consistent you have to
save lives and I actually to in my in my
view it is not about the religion
actually a feeling of being betrayed
being forgotten they contribute so much
during the revolutions and this is the
area the last area that was defeated by
the Dutch they feel like betrayed not so
it's Thomas yes thank you very much
discussion I was in Indonesia lives here
at boot Owatonna and it's not too good
ICRS
also manages all unfamiliar repeat to
institution but you mentioned I think
with our dinner because you have
mentioned the young people's lack of
knowledge and this is a real challenge
to make college most working groups are
trying to respond it is a lack of
knowledge of Islamic teaching or is it a
lack of knowledge of the Islamic and
Japanese roots of Han Cecila does it
both you know you mentioned several you
mentioned how an Cecila is sort of a
middle way this one Indonesia however
it's also Javanese right it's a kind of
a philosophical construction - so is it
because of globalization that young
people are attractive for this radical
idea and can is local communities
provide where you might sit call
remedial socialization is that possible
in today's world you are as I also
mentioned earlier that the price of
radicalism is not because of single
factor the globalization is palpable but
the rampant corruption and the gaps and
at the same time those radicals who came
with a fresh idea about what so called
twisted Islam and
try to invite them to be a good Muslim
by convincing them that while you
Indonesian so far practicing Islam and
you end up with this kind of frustration
this is because of your Islam is wrong
yeah so come together and try to create
an Islamic understanding an Islamic
state which then being practiced at full
and going back to the early generation
this is an attractive invitation linking
the teaching of Islam with the current
situation psychologically and acceptable
and frustration of the rampant
corruption and don't forget that the
year those radical penetrates the heart
and mind of the youth especially by
saying that you Muslim are being
marginalized look who are the richest
among the rich how many Muslims there
fear you see this is a very powerful
argument
so therefore the president can sense
this radicalism is not only ideological
a factor but the ideology like putting
fire on putting gas on the already
existing fire so now President jokowi
announced that he is trying to get
and productive land even though owned by
people to be distributed to the poor and
through the Poisson trends through the
traditional school who are mostly having
this kind of frustration and at the same
time also announced that he will he
invite Muslim scholars to come with
proposal of economic endeavor business
and he is asking them because they want
them to accept this idea and has already
forced the conglomerate to share some of
their money to be the capital of this
kind of new enterprises gets to address
the issue and from the top we I spent an
amazing session mostly for me we have a
reception waiting for us but I wonder if
I might just summarize very briefly what
we've had here emotional talking began
by affirming that Islam is compatible
with democracy as a kind of fundamental
premise of the work they have been doing
in Indonesia we have been alerted to the
danger of a radical ideology penetrating
the Indonesian society and a kind of
implicit challenge to the West joins
Indonesia in meeting this contemporary
challenge
not only challenge for Indonesia it's a
challenge for the international
community and I would say according to
Marx we've already had and this panel is
a challenge also to Islam in that it is
a distortion of the spiritual message of
Islam to twist it into political
spectrum ISM the third of course is the
profile of Indonesian Islam Indonesian
Muslims are fairly low-key in
international organizations and
Indonesian Islam doesn't have a very
high profile in the discussions about
Islam involvement in relief work
hospital care and so forth and so on and
and that this profile of Indonesian
Islam is not only for domestic
consumption but it's also for sharing
widely in the campaign not only against
radical Islam but in the campaign to
recover the initiatives of Islam itself
as a spiritual force in the lives of
Muslims all over the world when I was in
Jakarta I did here because I saw others
speak about the sort of lively Islam or
relaxed Islam at this flowering of Islam
is enthusiastic Islam and I was reminded
because of the nature of the audience
that this is really batik Islam
envisioned formal Islam where the image
is imprinted on the fabric but that
image comes in different shapes and
sizes and colors but the batik the
fabric is strong enough
to hold those images without the fabric
tearing apart or without distorting
those images either and it seems to me
that special sly genius of Indonesian
Islam it's like a good dish is worth
sharing with the rest of the world thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]